este problema dice resuelve y elimina
cualquier solución extraña bueno a lo
que se refieren con solución extraña en
este contexto es que puede ser que al
manipular esta expresión obtengamos
algunos valores tales que parezcan
solución pero cuando los sustituimos en
esta igualdad original no tienen sentido
porque hacen que algunos de los lados
queda indefinido va entonces como esas
soluciones no funcionan en la ecuación
original tenemos que descartar las esta
ecuación es x al cuadrado entre x + 2 es
igual a 4 entre x + 2
entonces en ambos lados de la ecuación
estamos dividiendo entre x + 2 por lo
tanto tenemos que cuidar que x sea
distinto de menos 2 o sea todavía no
sabemos si x igual a menos 12 solución o
no pero para evitar que dividamos entre
0 tenemos que pedir que x x no sea no
sea menos 2 si algunas de las soluciones
que obtenemos al manipular esto queda
igual a menos 2 tenemos que descartar la
bueno ya teniendo en mente que x no es
igual a menos 2
ahora si podemos multiplicar por x2 de
ambos lados de esta igualdad podemos
multiplicar por x2 acá y por x + 2 acá
para cancelar estos denominadores este
se cancela con este este se cancela con
este y nos quedaría que x al cuadrado y
x al cuadrado es igual a 4 ahora
podríamos resolver esto de aquí
mentalmente pero vamos a hacerlo un
poquito más formal vale así como una
ecuación cuadrática entonces déjame
pasar el 4 restando al lado izquierdo
entonces restamos 4 de ambos lados y nos
quedan x cuadrada menos 4 es igual a
cero ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
factorizar esto porque es una diferencia
de cuadrados nos quedaría que x 2 x x 2
es igual a 0 y bueno como tenemos el
producto de dos números y ese producto
es igual a cero entonces algunos de los
factores o los dos tienen que ser igual
a cero suponiendo que el primer factor
es cero tenemos que x más 2 es igual a
cero suponiendo que el segundo factor es
igual a cero nos queda x menos 2 es
igual a 0 y de este lado restando 2 en
ambos lados de la igualdad obtenemos que
x es igual a menos 2 y acá sumando 2 en
ambos lados tenemos qué
es igual a 2 de esta forma dos y menos
dos hacen que se quita al cuadrado menos
40 igual a 0 y por tanto que quizá al
cuadrado sea igual a 4 pero ahora hay
que tener cuidado con esto que dijimos
de las soluciones extrañas porque de
acuerdo a nuestra condición de acá x
debe ser distinto de menos 2 así que
está la x igual a menos 2 en realidad no
es una solución luego si es una solución
de esto de ya la manipulación pero no es
solución de la igualdad original porque
estaríamos dividiendo entre 0 de esta
forma como estamos descartando x igual a
menos 2 nos queda que la única solución
es x igual a 2x igual a 2 vale y bueno
ya pensando que esta es la única
solución también se puede verificar es
más vamos a hacerlo vamos a ver si de
veras satisface la ecuación original
tendríamos que comprobar que 2 al
cuadrado o sea 4 dividido entre 2 más 2
o sea 4 es igual
4 dividido entre 2 más 2 o sea entre 4 y
pues si estoy aquí es cierto porque uno
es igual a 1